The Yonko are without a doubt some of the
strongest characters in One Piece. like Big
Mom and Kaido have ruled the New World for
decades because of their insanely powerful
devil fruits. Whitebeard was considered the
world’s strongest man thanks to his absurdly
destructive Tremor fruit and even Blackbeard is
becoming the number one threat to Luffy due to
his overpowered darkness fruit. Which leaves
a very interesting question on the table:
What would happen if Luffy ate
the Yonko Devil Fruits instead?
And just like the other videos we have done in
this series, we will be starting all the way
back from when Luffy was a kid to see exactly how
he would use the fruit, if the fruit would change
his personality at all, and most importantly
if each fruit will help him become pirate king.
What you might not believe though is that even
though all of the Yonko’s fruits are super
powerful, we are going to find out that Luffy is a
terrible user of some of these fruits, and he may
not even make it to the time skip. Plus, most of
the Yonko are just stupidly strong on their own,
and would probably have become an Emperor
even without their fruits. For example,
Kaido was a super powered demon oni
who was taking out entire countries
as a kid. And even as a child, Big Mom
took out an entire village of giants,
which we have to be honest and say that
Luffy is nowhere close to that powerful,
so he’s going to have to be creative or
his pirate journey will end very quickly.
But first, let’s begin back in the bar with
Shanks in chapter one. This was where child
Luffy first ate the devil fruit that Shanks and
his crew had stolen from a world government ship.
So for this scenario let’s just imagine
that instead of Luffy’s original fruit,
Shanks brought back this fruit instead. Which
means that when Luffy takes a massive chomp,
the bar instantly starts to shake.
That’s because Luffy has just eaten
Whitebeard’s Gura-Gura no mi, which allows
the user to create massive vibrations that
can literally destroy islands. In fact, we
saw Whitebeard use these powers to create
massive waves, island shattering earthquakes,
and even deliver face-crunching punches .
However, while this fruit is extremely
powerful with its raw destructive potential,
I actually think this fruit is one of the WORST
abilities for Luffy to use because I can just
imagine that ten seconds after eating the devil
fruit he would probably already have destroyed the
bar. Which might mean that Shanks would have to
knock him out of something if Luffy can’t control
his powers. Because one thing to keep in mind
is that we don’t know when Whitebeard got this
devil fruit. To me, it makes sense that he got
it at God Valley when he was already an adult,
so if that was true then Whitebeard would
have had a much better chance at controlling
these powers than a young, reckless kid like
Luffy. Even Blackbeard when he first ate the
Tremor fruit had very little control and
nearly destroyed all of Marineford. So I
personally wouldn’t want to be anywhere near
Earthquake Luffy because who knows when he
could just lose control and break the ground
underneath you. Plus, I even wonder if the
destructive nature of this devil fruit might
make Luffy’s personality even more reckless.
But let’s say Shanks sticks around a bit and helps
Luffy learn to at least control his new powers a
little bit, and then Luffy grows up like normal,
living in the jungle with Sabo and Ace. However,
instead of throwing rubber punches ch 585,
Luffy punches himself in the face, now his
training involves controlling massive vibrations.
Which means that even though he tries his best
to control his abilities, there are times
when kid Luffy still causes massive damage
on the island. And this could actually lead to
some truly awful bad situations. For example,
Luffy might accidentally crush Ace, Sabo, or
the bandits he grew up with. He could also
cause so much damage that the rulers of the Goa
kingdom send soldiers to capture Luffy. Or if it
is so bad, I wonder if Garp forces Luffy into the
marines to stop him from destroying the island.
Whatever happens, I think all of this might
either make Luffy more hesitant to use his
powers or on the other hand his personality
could change so that he cares less about the
destruction he causes. But let’s say after
ten years he can control his powers on land,
and now he is ready to set out to sea. At
this point, he is probably a pretty strong
fighter even without using his devil fruit
powers, which is super important because if
he makes a mistake and breaks his ship, then
say goodbye to Earthquake Luffy. So even with
just his base strength, he goes through
the East Blue without much difficulty,
but then the real problems occur when he
faces his first major challenge in Alabasta.
Because Luffy’s fight against the sand fruit user,
Crocodile, was the first time he was truly tested
in the story. And there is almost no chance
that Luffy can beat Crocodile with just his
base strength which would mean he has to use his
tremor abilities. However, since this is the first
time he is using his powers in a life or death
situation, I think it is completely reasonable
to think he could cause massive destruction to
the capital city of Alabasta. Which means that
even if he defeats Crocodile, he would probably
have killed tons of civilians in the process,
which would make him less of a hero and
more of an extremely wanted villain.
Which will send his bounty sky high, but not
in a good way. And if this continues on the
islands that he visits, then eventually
the marines would have no choice but to
send a strong fighter such as an admiral to put
an end to Earthquake Luffy’s pirate adventure.
So yeah, it’s not all about just
having a super strong devil fruit,
but more important to have the right devil
fruit for the right person at the right time.
Which is why this next devil fruit is actually a
perfect match for Luffy to eat as a kid. Because
let’s head back to chapter one, and now it is
this fruit that has caught Luffy’s hungry eyes.
And with a single bite, all of a sudden the slab
of meat that is on Luffy's plate suddenly starts
talking to the very confused Luffy. And before
Luffy can shove the talking piece of meat in
his mouth, Shanks absolutely loses his mind
that Luffy has just eaten the Soul Fruit.
Now as a reminder, this fruit allows the user to
take pieces of soul and use them to turn objects,
plants, or animals into actual intelligent
creatures. So that hunk of meat on Luffy’s
plate can now talk and think for itself. We saw
Big Mom use this fruit to create entire islands
full of homies, such as this entire forest full
of living trees and animals. Even her ship was
given a piece of soul so it could sing. Now
Big Mom could take souls from other people,
but the important part for Luffy is
that Big Mom could also use her own
soul to create extra powerful homies,
like her cloud, sun, and hat-sword,
or she could take souls from other people, which
if she took too much would kill the person.
So as you might imagine, this is yet another
devil fruit that is going to take a ton of
practice for Luffy to learn how to use. However,
it isn’t quite as dangerous as the Tremor fruit,
so he should be able to spend a lot of
time mastering the devil fruit during his
years growing up. The only real danger
I can see is that Luffy would have too
much fun creating homies that he
uses up all of his own lifespan.
But let’s imagine that Shanks warns him
against using too much of his own soul.
And maybe Ace and Sabo will let Luffy
take some of their soul to use for fun,
and before Luffy leaves the island he has created
three main homies that he is going to take with
him. We have this cloud that lets him fly around
easily, a super powerful homie staff that Luffy
has learned to fight with. Which basically
makes him like kid Goku at this point. And
then of course his new straw hat homie, which
is mostly just a friend for him to talk to.
With these three, Luffy sets off on his journey.
The East Blue is again no problem at all since he
is strong enough on his own. Plus he can now fly,
so he could technically skip islands. However,
I do think he would still get a ship
since he would probably think it is
no fun to just skip every island along the
way. And with the help of his cloud homie,
defeating Crocodile in Alabasta is no
problem because the cloud can send rain
down on the sand fruit user, allowing
Luffy to smack Crocodile with his staff.
Next, going to Skypiea would be much simpler
since the cloud homie could expand to carry the
straw hat’s whole ship up to the sky islands. And
fighting against Enel would be super interesting
because I wonder if the cloud homie could absorb
all of Enel’s lighting or even the lightning user
himself. Either way, Luffy would eventually find
a clever way to defeat Enel or at least make it
so that his massive thundercloud is no longer
a threat before Enel flies away to the moon.
Which brings us to Water 7. And here
Soul Luffy would easily be able to
catch up to the secret agents who took Robin
because of his cloud homie’s flying ability,
which would allow the straw hats to defeat
them before even reaching Enies Lobby. Man,
flying really is the most OP ability in the story.
That means Luffy’s next challenge is Thriller
Bark, which come on, is this really even a
challenge? But it might be cool to see homies
versus zombies. However, then the crew heads
to Sabaody, which is where we get our first
massive change in Soul Luffy’s journey. That’s
because with the help of his cloud, Luffy and
the crew would have a much easier time escaping
the cyborg Pacifistas and Admiral Kizaru after
Luffy punched the celestial dragon. This means
that the entire crew escapes unharmed, although
they have to leave their ship there for now.
But this brings us to the most important change
in Soul Luffy’s journey. Because it is right at
this time that Ace is about to be executed at
Marineford. So let’s assume that Luffy and the
crew find out about this somehow, and Luffy is
dead set on going to save him at Impel Down.
However, unlike the original story where Luffy
went through with his crazy prison break idea,
this time he has Nami around to knock
some sense into him. And since they
can fly around on the cloud, they simply wait
until Ace is being transported to Marineford,
swoop down to the marine ship, and rescue Ace
without even needing to go through the Summit War.
Wow, that was actually super easy. Which
also means that Whitebeard doesn’t need
to die at Marineford, and the crew next
meet up with the Emperor of the Sea to
drop off Ace. And I’m sure Whitebeard would
be super grateful for the crew saving Ace,
which means that he might even teach the Straw Hat
Crew haki and let them train with his commanders
as thanks. Which is extra important since we
are not having the normal two year timeskip.
I also wonder what other creative ways Luffy
would come up with to use his fruit. Maybe some
combo attacks using Brooks's Soul powers. Plus
maybe he could make poneglyphs into homies and
they could tell them more of the ancient
history. I’m sure Robin would love that
Now with the haki-buffed crew
ready to enter the New World,
it’s time to drop a controversial take because
I think that even though things have gone pretty
smoothly so far, I’m pretty sure that Soul
Luffy would be weaker than the original.
Because we have to remember that Big Mom was
a monster as a child. She took out an entire
village of giants at the age of five. There is
no way Luffy could do that. And when fighting,
Big Mom doesn’t use her devil fruit all that
much, except for the elemental abilities and
her giant sword. She is essentially just a
brawler who has insane levels of strength,
durability, and haki. So what this means is that
Soul Luffy would definitely need to train extra
hard with his haki since he doesn’t have the power
boosts that came from his original devil fruit.
But let’s assume that he does this, and
combined with his creative use of homies,
he goes through the New World without too
much trouble. This takes us to his inevitable
clashes with Big Mom and Kaido, where it
is hard to say what would happen. I mean,
these fights most often come down to advanced
haki abilities, but I do think Luffy could use
his devil fruit in more creative ways to help
during the battle. So in the end, I think Soul
Luffy would come out on top just like in the
original, and continue to find the One Piece.
However, even though Soul Luffy was pretty OP,
even that version of Luffy simply cannot compare
with the god-like powers of Chop Chop Luffy. And
I’m actually not kidding, because in case you
forgot Buggy the Clown is technically a Yonko now
which qualifies him for this video and his Chop
devil fruit powers are so completely perfect
for Luffy that he might even be able to do an
ultra speed run of the grand line and find the
One Piece in less than a year. Don’t believe
me? Then listen to this. This power lets you
separate your body into pieces which basically
makes you immune to swords. You can also fly
as long as your feet stay on the ground. So
I can just imagine Luffy finding all sorts of
creative ways to use this power, but I’m now
thinking about how incredible this fruit would be
if Luffy could combine it with his current devil
fruit. I mean Blackbeard has two devil fruits
so maybe it would be possible for Luffy. This
means that if you combine rubber and the chop
abilities then… Okay, hold on wait. This idea of
Luffy eating two fruits is really interesting,
so let's save it for a future video, and make
sure to subscribe if you want to see how Luffy
having two devil fruits would work in the story.
And since we are saving Buggy’s fruit,
let’s move on to one of the biggest devil
fruit powers in the story. So back in the
bar when Luffy takes a bite of this and he
immediately transforms into a little red dragon
and starts spitting fire everywhere. That’s right,
this is going to be Dragon Luffy.
However, there is a lot of confusion
around Kaido’s devil fruit because
it's officially the Fish fruit Model:
Seriyu, which is a famous blue dragon. And
since it is based on an old Japanese myth,
we aren’t sure if you turn into a fish first
and then later awaken his dragon abilities or
if it works like Momonoske’s version of the fruit
and you turn into a dragon right from the start?
Since we don’t know, let’s
go with the more exciting
option and assume that Luffy will be a
dragon right away. Although honestly,
it would be hilarious to see Luffy trying to
fight his way to the grand line as tiny fish.
Anyway, Luffy can now become a dragon who
has the mind-blowing ability to control
elements such as shooting out a giant
blast breath, calling down lightning,
and sending razor sharp gusts of wind. Which
means that by the time Luffy sets out at age 17,
he is a legendary creature with
incredible natural powers. However,
before we start we need to make a serious
disclaimer. Because just like Big Mom, Kaido
was an absolute powerhouse fighter who was able to
join the legendary Rocks crew even before he got
his legendary devil fruit. Which means that his
base power is absurdly high, which if I’m being
honest we probably cannot say about seventeen
year old Luffy when he starts his journey.
And unlike when Luffy had his cloud homie, I
do think Dragon Luffy would fly around more and
skip islands. That’s because as a dragon
he is literally the king of the beasts,
which might make Luffy more arrogant and not
bother with some of the smaller islands like
Syrup Village. However, maybe Zoro would
challenge him to not use his dragon form,
so he might still get some
practice in normal or hybrid forms.
The first half of the grand line would still
be a piece of cake because of the sheer power
Luffy can use as a dragon. He can bring
down rain to help defeat Crocodile,
match lightning powers with
Enel, and if I’m being honest,
he would probably wipe out CP9 before they
even came close to escaping with Robin.
However, let’s assume that Thriller Bark
and Sabaody go as usual, and the crew gets
separated. Luffy ends up on Amazon Lily and
finds out about Ace’s execution. Of course,
he wants to go save Ace, and this is where the
story is going to change dramatically. Because
there is no way that Dragon Luffy is waiting to
sneak on a marine ship. Instead, he would probably
fly to Impel Down himself and just start to
destroy the place with his blast breaths. However,
once he got inside the prison, things would be
MUCH MORE difficult. Since there is less space
inside the prison, he wouldn’t be able to use
his big dragon form, which at this point I think
would still be his most powerful since he doesn’t
know haki. So that means getting down to save Ace
would probably fail just like in the original
story and he would have to go to Marineford.
Which is going to end so badly for Dragon Luffy.
And that’s because since Luffy’s dragon form is
so powerful, he probably would not have the
massive levels of battle experience he would
need to make a difference during this epic
war. That means he would likely HAVE TO use
his big dragon form to have any effect on this
legendary battlefield. So with this big dragon
shooting fire, lightning, and wind gusts,
I think the admirals would have no choice
but to team up and take out Luffy before
he destroys all of Marineford. And maybe
you could say that Whitebeard would help protect
him, but honestly, since he is such a big target
I think Luffy would just take too much damage
from Kizaru’s light beams and Akainu’s magma,
which unfortunately means that Dragon Luffy
doesn’t even make it to the New World.
However, not even Dragon Luffy’s outcome is
as surprising as what is going to happen next.
Because back in the bar Luffy chomps down
on this innocent looking fruit and a pool
of darkness instantly sucks all of his friends
into the floor. Which makes Luffy completely
freaks out until he somehow manages to
spit everyone back out moments later.
Welcome to the story, Darkness Luffy. And Shanks
would probably throw a major fit over Luffy
eating this particular fruit, but this might
be one of the most interesting scenarios for
an alternate devil fruit. Because one thing we
haven’t discussed yet is that if Luffy eats a
different fruit, then someone else would likely
get Luffy’s original fruit. Let’s assume Shanks
still has the Nika fruit AND he plans to give
it to Ace, then that would mean that Luffy and
Ace would have the darkness and Sun God fruits.
Which would be just a mind-blowing turn of events,
And because the Darkness fruit belongs to the
main villain of the story, we actually know
quite a bit about its abilities. It is a special
logia that allows the user to produce darkness,
which kind of acts like a pocket dimension
that can suck things in and crush them with
darkness. But the most important ability
that darkness Luffy will use is the one
that allows him to suck in other devil
fruit users and take away their powers
as long as he is touching them. Which is
a broken ability in a world where most of
the strong fighters are devil fruit users. The
only downside is that Darkness Luffy won’t get
the normal logia invincibility since it instead
absorbs all of the damage that he takes. Ouch.
Which brings us to the nature of this devil
fruit. And honestly, I think that it gets a
bad rap because we see it used by Blackbeard,
but there is nothing that tells us this power
is naturally evil. I mean it was originally
found by this guy, and can you imagine him
turning into a super villain if he ate the
fruit? So that means we can’t assume that
Darkness Luffy is automatically Evil Luffy, it
just means he has some pretty amazing powers.
However, I do think that this devil fruit would be
quite tough for Luffy to use, at least at first. I
mean, I can’t really see him crushing tons of
people and buildings with his darkness. Plus
absorbing all damage would be particularly painful
for Luffy since he is usually such a straight up
kind of fighter. And even worse, Darkness Luffy
wouldn’t have his rubber to help deflect some of
that damage. So Luffy is going to have to train
up his base strength and defense quite a bit,
and he may even use some sort of weapon
like a staff or club to help him fight.
But his ability to negate other devil
fruits is such a broken power that it
comes in handy right away. Facing Buggy? Just
suck him in and kick him in the balls. For the
rest of the East Blue, he’d have to rely
more on his own strength, but in the end,
I think he would reach the Grand
Line without too much difficulty.
And these next few arcs are going to be
basically target practice for Darkness
Luffy. Against Crocodile’s Sand, he can
just take away his powers. Same with Enel,
who without his lightning is like fighting
a cat without its claws. Honestly, though,
I do think Rob Lucci would probably be
a bigger challenge because he is pretty
strong even without his devil fruit, but
I still think Luffy would come out on top.
However, as Darkness Luffy continues toward
the New World, there is one other major
difference in the story. Since Blackbeard
doesn’t have his darkness fruit, there is
a good chance he is still on Whitebeard's
crew. And if Teach hears that Luffy has the
Darkness fruit he wanted all along, he would
probably come after Luffy right away. However,
I don’t think he would be able to beat
Luffy on his own unless there was some
kind of trick, so that means Blackbeard
is taken out of the story completely.
Which if you are paying attention means that Ace
is never captured, so Marineford never occurs.
Bam. Game changed.
However, before we move on to the New World, there
is one major dilemma that the crew will have to
face. What happens when Luffy meets Roger’s former
right hand, Rayleigh? And this is honestly a tough
question because we don’t know the full history
of the Yami Yami no mi. One theory is that the
infamous pirate Rocks previously ate the fruit,
and if that’s the case would Rayleigh still help
Luffy since the straw hat captain has eaten
Rocks’ old fruit? I’m honestly not too sure.
However, let’s just say that
Rayleigh does help them,
and even trains them a bit with haki
before they head into the New World.
And just like the early parts of the Grand
Line, this is going to go incredibly well
for Darkness Luffy since he basically only
fights devil fruit users such as Caesar,
Doflamingo, Katakuri, and so on. Of course, the
real challenge comes against Kaido and Big Mom,
but with his special abilities, I feel like
he would be able to overcome the two devil
fruit using Yonko and continue
his path to find the One Piece.
Which is honestly pretty surprising and not
what I expected AT ALL for Darkness Luffy
when I started writing this script. However,
even though Luffy made it this far with two
out of the four Yonko fruits, these are actually
not even the most powerful devil fruits in the
story. In fact, many of those insane
devil fruits belong to the Warlords,
so if you want to know how Luffy’s story
would go with fruits like Kuma’s reality
bending Paw fruits or Doflaminog’s String
fruit, you can watch this video right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.